[Music]
for almost 70 years the simple iconic
Lego brick has captivated the
imaginations of children around the
world and in 2023 the LEGO Group for the
ninth consecutive year took the throne
as the world's hottest toy maker what's
their secret Well turns out kids weren't
the only ones who had Lego sets on their
wish list while sales peaked during the
height of the co9 lockdowns the LEGO
Group has maintained an average growth
of 14% since they began marketing for in
2019 the sudden boom in a Falls that's
adult fans of Lego for those not
familiar begs the question why is a
mature audience so captivated by simple
plastic building blocks I think it just
happened kind of um what's the right
word um
serendipitously that's Jean Viv Kaa Cruz
the Lego group's adult portfolio head
she said that once they realized adults
were buying kids Lego sets for
themselves they decided to try desig for
adults as well and fella Groves one of
the company's lead designers said it was
one of the best decisions they ever made
designing for adults is particularly
interesting compared to design for kids
because you're spending so much time you
know like reliving those memories you
know in that sort of like nostalgic Lane
so when we kind of seed in those we know
that you know these are the emotional
hooks that can really mean something for
the consumer at the other end and in the
last four years new licensing agreements
have opened doors of possibility for
sport and car enthusiasts art lovers and
pop culture fans of all kinds those are
the kinds of products that um some of
our adult uh consumers really really
love you know the these things that just
remind you of those days of innocense a
study from the LEGO Group found that 69%
of adult Canadians say Lego helps them
try new things and feel productive while
also taking them back to their childhood
I had to get Voltron because Voltron is
is part of my my childhood and Mark
Andre de bruy a commercial director and
longtime Lego collector can attest my
kids sit here for hours just looking
around and and you know they bring their
friends over and they just sit and they
look it just kind of brings me back to
my childhood when I used to do that with
my father and um kind of sharing that
kind of bond between was was something
really special the LEGO Group study also
found that 88% of adults worldwide
believe that playing with Lego is a
great way to spend time with family or
friends it is something that has brought
my son and I Incredibly Close he has
autism so playing with Lego has really
helped him you know with his mechanical
and just you know it's just a it's a fun
challenge it's like building a puzzle
others consider the colorful blocks to
be a perfect date night on the weekends
there are times when we'll you know
spend hours it's morning already we we
spent what about 30 40 minutes or
whatever just putting together a small
Christmas set when Rick and Sarah aren
traveling the world with their Lego
minifigure family they're at home
planning new additions for their Lego
Metropolis last weekend we were we were
with our one of our kids in Ottawa and
you know we're sitting there in the
restaurant dry on a napkin how we might
reconfigure how the city tables fit
together so we could get a better layout
it's fun yeah you're never mad at Lego
and for some adults Lego play helps
eleviate stress in many different ways
something many fans can speak to given
that one in eight people worldwide
suffer with mental health disorders
having Lego is just you know a way to
just take a moment and maybe forget the
the pressures and and hardships of life
in Canada alone it's considered an
activity that helps 73% relax and feel
calm 72% use the hobby as a form of
relief from the worries of everyday life
while 71% say it helps maintain mental
sharpness and 68% of poor respondents
found that Lego player allows them to
wind down after work it takes away the
responsibility from decision making for
a while it's kind of nice to just be
told what to do in a very beautiful
format speaking about the practice of
mindfulness one of the Lego group's key
initiatives habby heeden the author of
Lego build yourself happy told us play
in general is important for adults
because so much of what we do every day
is directed towards a goal actually
playing in the way that children do is
something that Fades out of adult life
all too easily and Lego gives us one way
of letting in a child loose for a little
while property Economist Josh mangl sold
almost his entire Lego collection in
2019 to be able to afford a down payment
on a house selling off his collection
didn't stop mangon from getting back
into the hobby though because for him it
was never just an investment but a way
to relax and simply enjoy a moment I
think you know there's there's an
element to it that gives you some
control and some order and that sort of
things that people look for in life and
don't always find people are generally
so worried about the next big thing in
their lives that they often forget to
enjoy the moment according to psychology
Professor Norm Fab but he says Lego play
is a rewarding activity that offers much
more than just a quick Escape so it it
kind of draws you in connecting with um
with a POS with positive emotion in the
moment and that in itself is really can
be really restorative and help keep the
brain wired and not just towards
avoidance a 2020 report from the Journal
of health education Echo Norm statement
and explores the benefits adults
experience using Lego as a creative
Outlet although Lego in one way is it's
like it's a this is not actually house
it is a model of a house but it is
actually like you're building this thing
and you really are creating something
that wasn't organized before right and
so you're having a visceral experience
of of accomplishment or positivity or
connection to the moment um and it's not
just avoidance through the success of
his own custom Lego Star Wars Creations
Jay has amassed approximately 60,000 sub
subscribers on YouTube fostering an
entire Community where Lego enthusiasts
share and discuss their Creations some
of my closest friends now have come into
my life because of my community because
of Lego which is so cool because
obviously like I'm super passionate
about it it's something that I'm dealing
with every single day and um to have
people to share that love with is just
the best thing ever and it's communities
like cheers who inspired the LEGO Group
to begin marketing for a mature
demographic in the first place we are
very much inspired and and to alert a
degree in awe of the level of creativity
that some of our fans have so whether
you consider an outlet of creativity a
way to travel back in time a tool to
help build and Foster relationships or a
method to let loose after a stressful
day the possibilities of Lego like the
Creations we can make with it are
Limitless Adam Wallace Global
News